hi there steve kaufman here today and
today i want to talk a little bit about
saving phrases tagging phrases and how i
work with phrases on link
i'm also going to do a
separate video today
just showing a few random shots of
constitution day in la viv ukraine
because i still haven't got
ukraine out of my brain i had a
wonderful time there in fact last night
i spoke to solomia uh via skype we had a
lesson in ukrainian but mostly i'm
focused on greek
and i want to show you how i'm saving
phrases so if i go to the app here
and let's go to i'm in the let's go back
to the lessons here and
let's just look at one lesson for
example
so here is a lesson that i'm studying
at link it's lesson number 24 in our
many stories series which i find very
helpful
and so typically i read through
and i might say
you know
a word but i'll typically say the phrase
when you heard that phrase every time i
say the phrase i hear it in text to
speech
scientific
uh i say i mark that as present tense
because i'm concerned about the tenses
in greek
uh the next
phrase so that's
i call that
instrumental because i'm copying from
slavic languages with his new
um
suit right and and so that's how i
remember it uh
that's why i tagged that as future tense
um
[Music]
purpose i tag that so you can tag it as
whatever you want
that's some kind of past tense i think
it's the imperfect tense
uh if i'm not sure one of the
dictionaries we have connected to here
is called cool jugator so i can look up
the conjugations just to make sure that
i've tagged it correctly in
more and more of our languages now we
have these grammar related
[Music]
dictionaries so that you can look things
up now what do i do with these i go to
the vocabulary section and that pops my
vocabulary and it shows that i have 9579
terms that i have saved words and
phrases links as we call them that's an
awful lot to review so i say let's just
look at phrases so i tap phrases here
and now only the phrases come up but the
phrases they're still
2550 phrases that's a lot to review so i
hit the search filters and i say let's
tag let's have a look at i mean i got
accusative adjective adverb
uh you know future uh
let's go to the imperfect because a lot
of imperfect shows up in greek
and so i apply that
and now i'm gonna get a list of
just those phrases that i saved
which have the imperfect
and uh
[Music]
so i go through these and i get a
concentrated dosage of the imperfect
tense in use again if i have doubts as
to whether in fact i tagged it correctly
because it's difficult in greek whether
this is in fact what they call the hour
is tense or the imperfect tense i can
always look it up on cooljugator just to
confirm that i got it right
and what this does is by reviewing these
phrases
initially sort of in this list and then
seeing them again
when i read the text it just gradually
helps me notice even the fact that i am
trying to save this phrase and tag it
for a specific
uh
tense or a specific purpose and then
even the fact sometimes of looking it up
uh
via one of these grammar reference
dictionaries it just helps me notice it
when i next see it when i next hear it
and so by focusing on phrases you are
starting to notice the structures of the
language better
and
to me noticing as i've said before is a
big part of language learning you can't
learn something that you don't notice
sometimes you have to force yourself to
notice or it'll just pass you by
even noticing it doesn't mean you'll
remember it doesn't mean you can use it
correctly but it's that
drip drip drip process of making you
more and more familiar with different
aspects of the language in addition when
you save a phrase you're also saving the
words that are there and so that's an
additional opportunity to review these
words and i think
a phrase can be as long as you want it
like and typically i'll save first the
word so that i can look up
what that part of speech or tense is
then i'll save a short phrase that
encompasses that
word and then i may even say a longer
phrase maybe even as long as a sentence
if the sentence isn't too long but the
advantage of phrases over sentences is
that phrases repeat and sentences
typically are more unique
so or i might save the whole sentence
just to hear it in text to speech
but then
say i don't need this and so that i
don't include that in the phrases that i
save for later review that's how i do it
people you know they can find their own
way of doing it um
again i am looking to demonstrate on my
computer and on my ipad how i do these
things i think that's of interest to
people
but i would be interested in hearing
about the best software for capturing
videos where i can read over and explain
what i'm doing i haven't yet found a
satisfactory software for creating these
videos from my computer or for that
matter if it's possible on my ipad
so
uh thank you for listening that there
you have it i look forward to hearing
from you if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe and i will put up a
separate video of some short videos from
uh constitution day which was one of the
last days that i had in the lovely city
of la vie thank you for listening
[Music]
you